τοταεμια φωτογραφία ένα βείταιο μια τάκα δεν είναι όλα όμως αυτά αυτά είναι σημαντικά πλαώ
να αναπόφευτα πεζουόλων αλλά ακόμα και στην περίψωση του φιδίαο φιίας δεν εξετάζωτα υπόλιβαή τα
διάφορα που κάπνει το ευροκινοβούλιο αλλά ανδι στην προεκλογϊκή του εστρατί έβγαζε κάτι το οποίον
δεν βρίσκεισε πολούς πολιτικούς στην κύπρο σήμερα εβγαζε μια αναυθεντικότητα τι έλεγε του κοσμοφιδιας εν
έχω ιδέα λέει τους του ευροκοινόπολή αλλά είμαι δια τεθυμένους να μάθο αυτόν είναι μια
αλήθεια παρά να βλέπεις υποψήιους τς ευροεκλογίές για παράδλα όχι τα ξέρον όλα να σου
να σου υπόσοχονται πράματα που ο μέσως πολί της μπορεί να αντιλιυθεί ότι και να
εκλαιγεής κύρι ευρώβουλευτής τίποτε που του τα ούλα πό μας λαλή σε μπορείς να κάνεις
ε μπορείς να αλλάξει στην μπορεία της ευρώπης επειδίεκλαίγεσεση στην ευρόολη ρά στην περίπψωση του
φδα κάποιος θα μπορούσε να επιμάλει στα κύριε τούτος να αναθεί να θυμίσω όσι προθυμοποιηθεήκαν
να κανούν φρον τη τήρια που φδία μετά την εκλοκήτού διότι ο φιδίας επουλούσες και
ξαφνικά θέλαμε όλι να πειδήσουμε πάνω στο παγόνι του φιδα για να αποκτίσουμε ράακόμα και
οφιδίας προσπάθησε να βάλει μια αναστινπούμενουσία στον πολιτικών του λόγο βλέπουμε όμως φαινόμενα τα οποία
δεν έχουν καμίαν δεν δείχνουν να μπαίνουν όχι σε βάθος οσύνουλιν τη επιφάνεια της πολιτικής
και να βάζουν όλα τα τα αυγά τους στο κομμάτι της επικοινωνίαείναι τα λλαεκψη σίγουρα
όχι ο σίγουρα χι κάποιαι όμως το βλέπον έτσι θεωρούν ότι τα πως έχουν τόσε
χιλιάδε άρ γιατί να μη η δοκιμάσουν μαμε διαλογική υπάρχουν οι ύμφλουενσερςι οποίαι έχουν πολύ
περισσότερες αλλά ε καιφόλοου ερς στοίστα κράμ της τοφερίςι αυτό και ακοαδαδι πολύ